[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le journal de
tv 78 nous sommes le jeudi 6 mai tout de
suite les titres de cette édition un
déploiement progressif des tests
salivaires dans l'académie de versailles
après les écoles primaires les collèges
entre également dans la campagne
reportage dans un établissement de
vélizy villacoublay où la rectrice
charline avenel s'est rendu ce matin
dans un peu plus d'un mois se tiendront
les élections départementales c'est au
programme les 20 et 27 juin nouvelle
étape dans le scrutin les candidats sont
désormais connus dans les 21 cantons des
yvelines en tout 80 ans binômes sont en
lice les détails à suivre
et puis du sport dans ce journal avec le
début du linxea open au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la compétition
regroupe 120 sportifs sur trois jours de
tournoi organisé par la fédération
française de golf l'objectif est de
rassembler golfeur amateur et
professionnel
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres la
cérémonie s'est tenue ce matin à la
caserne de rambouillet les pompiers ont
rendu un dernier hommage au caporal
justin almeida en présence de sa famille
collègues et amis le jeune pompier
volontaire de 19 ans est décédé vendredi
30 avril dans un accident de moto à son
chant il se rendait à la caserne pour
prendre son service ce jour-là justin le
meddat devait participer au dispositif
de sécurité de l'hommage national rendu
à stéphanie mon fermé est la policière
assassiné par un terroriste une semaine
plus tôt
le pont qui a été décoré lors de cette
cérémonie à titre posthume après les
écoles primaires depuis le mois de mars
c'est au tour des collèges d'entrer dans
la campagne de vaccination la campagne
de tests salivaires par donc au vide 19
je vous en parlais dans les titres sur
la base du volontariat des élèves les
établissements de l'académie de
versailles déploie ses dépistages c'est
le cas par exemple au collège de
vélizy-villacoublay saint-exupéry où la
salle polyvalente a été transformé pour
l'occasion le reportage ce matin de
mélanie poker par groupes de seize ces
élèves vont se faire dépister contre le
coronavirus au collège saint-exupéry de
vélizy villacoublay
les tests salivaires sont arrivés cette
semaine c'est très très important de que
les élèves soient testés parce que ça
permet justement si un élève
alko vide et que l'on doit fermer la
classe de la ferme est beaucoup plus
rapidement avant que le virus ne se
propage
donc pour nous c'est très important
quarante mille tests seront réalisés
dans l'académie de versailles de manière
hebdomadaire 10000 concerne directement
le département des yvelines avec pour
moitié dans les collèges
les tests salivaires ont un avantage
ce qui est important c'est que c'est un
petit peu moins invasif que des tests
antigénique donc du coup ça suscite une
adhésion de la part des jeunes qui
qui est plus grande et donc par là nous
arrivons à toucher davantage de jeunes
et leurs familles sont souvent aussi
plus enclines à
les autoriser à faire cet instant cet
établissement accueille 610 élèves pour
22 classes dont quatre ont dû fermer
avant les vacances
avec un peu de gêne parfois et de
sourires les adolescents se font tester
sur la base du volontariat
je pense que c'est plutôt une bonne idée
pour savoir si tout le monde est petit
pour savoir si tout se passe bien si
peut-être des cas dans le collège comme
ça ça a été évité la côte est ne sont
déjà craché ventes un peu bizarre en a
qui disent ça fait un peu mal et c'est
désagréable en classe la semaine
prochaine les lycées de l'académie de
versailles seront à leur tour concernés
cette fois ce sont des autotests qui
seront déployés un nouveau coup
d'accélérateur cette fois ci pour la
campagne de vaccination emmanuel macron
a fait des annonces en ce sens ce matin
à partir du lundi 10 mai d'abord la
vaccination sera ouverte à toutes les
personnes de plus de 50 ans et dès
demain vendredi la prise de rendez-vous
sera disponible pour cette tranche d'âge
autre annonce importante du président de
la république à partir du 12 mai la
vaccination sera ouverte sans limite
d'âge mais uniquement lorsqu'il reste
des doses de vaccin pour ne pas les
gâcher a dit le chef de l'état
il faudra regarder la veille sur le site
d'octo l'iba si des doses sont
disponibles si tel est le cas et des
créneaux seront ouverts sans limite
d'âge
enfin la direction générale de la santé
a également fait une autre annonce les
mineures de 16 et 17 ans souffrant d'une
pathologie à très haut risque sont
autorisés à être vaccinés avec le vaccin
fader le 19 mai prochain sera lancée la
deuxième étape du calendrier du
déconfinement qui a été enclenchée par
le gouvernement une date attendue avec
impatience par les commerçants qui
pourront rouvrir leurs boutiques fermées
en attendant la reprise des discussions
ont lieu c'était le cas tout récemment
aux clayes sous bois où élus et
commerçants ont été changés il a été
notamment question de l'aide apportée
aux commerçants par le département
bixente mayence insisté ban a un temps
des échanges entre élus locaux et
commerçants des clayes-sous-bois pour ce
peuvent mener pendant la coved les
discussions autour des difficultés
actuelles ont été rassurantes
le fait que la mairie nous soutiennent
dans nos démarches et nous aident pour
la réouverture des terrasses qui vont
démarrer le 19 axes majeurs du dialogue
la mesure d'être d'urgence au commerce
de proximité
financé par le département nous avons
entendu que 40 commerces sur les 150 des
clayes-sous-bois allez pouvoir
bénéficier de cette aide alors donc on
n'a pas encore le nom de toutes les
sociétés et tous les commerces qui vont
pouvoir en bénéficier
mais c'est une réelle aide surtout dans
cette période une aide pouvant aller
jusqu'à dix mille euros selon la nature
de l'activité et la durée d'interdiction
d'accueillir du public
ils sont tous exprimés bien entendu une
grande satisfaction de disposer de ces
aides demandées dans des temps aussi
difficile que ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui
parce que comme ils l'ont et comme ils
n'ont précisé
pour certains il ne faisait que 10 à 20
% de leur chiffre d'affaires j'ai pu
voir que il était tout à fait à
l'enquete à fait prêt à repartir de
l'avant et que l'aide que le département
leur avait apporté était ce socle sur
lequel ils pouvaient alors pas forcément
que matériellement mais aussi
psychologiquement rebond rebondir il
avait le sentiment de ne pas être seul
comme inquiétude partagée entre élus et
commerçants les enjeux de la reprise de
l'activité avec la peur d'une pénurie de
main d'oeuvre au moment de la
réouverture dans l'actualité politique
les habitants de chevreuse appelés aux
urnes ce dimanche 9 mai et ce après
l'annulation de l'élection municipale de
mars 2020 suite un recours effectivement
déposé au tribunal administratif
une élection partielle est organisée
tout comme l'an passé deux listes
s'affrontent pour la mairie celle
d'annie le pallec maire sortante et
celle de sébastien cattaneo pour rappel
le 15 mars 2020 à néry le pallec avait
été réélu avec seulement une voix
d'écart un recours avait été déposé par
sébastien à cattaneo après jugement puis
appelle le conseil d'état avait confirmé
qu'un des bulletins pour sébastien
cattaneo avait été invalidée à tort
annulant de fait cette élection les
élections départementales elles
approchent également le scrutin est au
programme les 20 et 27 juin prochains et
la liste des binômes en course pour ce
scrutin est connu dans les yvelines
les candidats avaient jusqu'à
hier mercredi 5 mai pour s'enregistrer
en préfecture tour d'horizon les forces
en présence se révèle 91 binôme composé
d'une femme et d'un homme sont en lice
dans les 21 cantons des yvelines pour
les élections départementales
c'est dans celui des mureaux mais aussi
de mantes la jolie kylie a le plus de
candidats sept binômes au total le
mantois ou pire bédié est en course pour
un nouveau mandat le président sortant
du département est aux côtés de la
première adjointe de mantes la ville
ils portent ensemble pour les yvelines
la liste de droite et du centre qui
avait remporté l'intégralité des cantons
en 2015 et qui a investi de nouveaux 21
binôme pour ce scrutin
dans ce canton les principales forces
politiques sont d'ailleurs présentes la
république en marche avec khadija mounib
et alain le cam le parti présidentiel
est également en course à versailles 1
avec anne francs si mon ancienne
candidate aux municipales dans la ville
et laurent de basta ils font face à
quatre autres binômes candidats présence
de rm également à bonnières sur seine où
s'affrontent quatre candidatures tout
comme pour montigny le bretonneux avec
en lice aussi les maires de guyancourt
françois morton et de montigny lorrain
merker attraper la candidature elle
errait mai portée notamment par le maire
du mesnil saint denis christophe bureau
et fait face à cinq autres binômes
notamment l'un composé du maire de
trappes ali rabais et un autre avec
l'édile de la verrière nicolas dainville
le rassemblement national de son côté
investi 20 binôme et a apporté son
soutien à un autre aligné dans le canton
de saint germain en laye dans celui de
mantes la jolie le rn a choisi d'opposer
au président sortant du département un
duo composé de l'ancien numéro un du
parti dans les yvelines mathilde andrew
et et de l'ex maire de mantes la ville
cyril note élus pendant six ans dans la
commune
c'est aussi dans ce canton de
mantes-la-jolie que la gauche fait quasi
front commun avec une candidature
commune de la france insoumise d'europe
écologie les verts et du parti
socialiste
portée par audrey alliés dylan guelton
et avec monique brochot et pierre
stillman en suppléant union qui n'est
pas effective sur l'ensemble des 21
cantons du département
la gauche y est certes présentes mais se
lance en ordre dispersé aligné dans de
nombreux cantons la candidature d'europe
écologie les verts par exemple est porté
notamment par le co secrétaire régional
du parti david jutier rambouillet contre
trois autres been
candidat les élections départementales
tout comme les régionales sont
programmées les 20 et 27 juin prochain
la liste de l'ensemble des binômes
candidat est consultable sur le site
internet de la préfecture des yvelines
direction à présent le golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines dès ce jeudi
120 joueurs professionnels ou amateurs
sont présents sur le site y vit loin
pour participer pendant trois jours au
linxea open le rendez-vous a notamment
attiré des têtes d'affichés sur place
pour en parler michael almy doro et
justine brasier le linxea open a débuté
ce jeudi 6 mai sous la pluie au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
que le rendez vous organisé par la
fédération française de golf rojo près
de 120 sportifs sur trois jours de
compétition le tournoi est mixte et il a
pour objectif de mêlée à la fois les
amateurs et les professionnels français
ya deux amateurs à partir moi je joue
avec deux amateurs de jeunes eux ça leur
permet de jouer avec des professionnels
ça leur permet de jouer sur un parcours
de compétition
avec cuba quant à eu un temps assez
compliqué
ces amateurs ont également le privilège
de jouer avec antoine or other le
pensionnaire du golf de la boulie à
versailles
le numéro deux français est venu se
préparer avant de s'envoler pour des
tournois aux états unis très content
c'est un peu dommage avec la météo
voilà c'est comme ça je suis très
content c'est un très bon entraînement
pour moi le parcours est superbe donc
non très content de pouvoir faire de
3,18 euros ici au golf national
l'autre star de ce rendez vous sera
également le parcours les joueurs vont
se tester sur ce 18 trous qui a
accueilli les meilleurs joueurs du monde
pendant la ryder cup 2018 et la magie
opère toujours
bien qu'elle va dresser un des parcours
la culture du franc qui peu après je
pense qu'il ya plus dur mais surtout
avec les conditions de paris historique
le golf depuis la ryder cup est encore
meilleur qu'avant donc forcément
forcément c'est vraiment des moments
privilégiés le tournoi league c'est à
open se terminera ce samedi 8 mai sur
les greens de l'albatros l'eau rendez
vous se déroulera à huis clos pendant
l'ensemble de l'épreuve
seul hic c'est open est aussi l'occasion
pour le golf national de renouer avec la
compétition en pleine crise sanitaire
regardez cette interview du direct du
directeur du site philippe pilato nous
sommes au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à mes côtés à
philippe pilato le directeur du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
alors philippe qu'est ce que ça
représente le linxea ff golf pour le
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
mais pour nous c'est une belle
opportunité c'est vrai que de recevoir
recevoir ce tournoi sur cette semaine
semaine qui était et est dédié à l'open
de france c'était une excellente
nouvelle pour l'ensemble des équipes
parce qu'en fait le site a été conçu
pour pouvoir recevoir des compétitions
de haut niveau des compétitions
professionnelles compétitions amateurs
de haut niveau et retrouver un petit peu
l'élite l'élite française sur le site du
golf national c'est une main j'ai
quelque chose d'extraordinaire ça s'est
fait un petit peu à la dernière minute
ça s'est passé comment ben en fait ça
s'est passé que l open de france l'open
de france est reporté dans le calendrier
est donc mais on avait cette sacralité
un jeu presque de la crise sanitaire et
donc voilà donc on avait une semaine
vacante des équipes mobilisées sur
l'événement et un parcours qui avait été
commencé à préparer on avait on avait
préparé le parcours de façon à ce qu'ils
soient opérationnels pour le plein de
france est donc en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est que la fédération a trouvé à
trouver un sponsor sponsors qui s'est
positionné de façon à pouvoir accueillir
cet événement ça permet au golf national
de continuer un petit peu
sa vie d'avant si je peux dire d'avoir
des compétitions de haut niveau
bah oui oui c'est exactement ça c'est
vrai que l'ensemble des collaborateurs
sur le terrain c'est vrai que ça donne
ça donne sommes dans nos objectifs
dans l'année ça permet de re mobiliser
les équipes ça permet un
de sortir un petit peu de la zone de
confort et de proposer de proposer
quelque chose
enfin un produit qui est en tout cas un
parcours qui est qui est fin prêt pour
accueillir ce tournoi oui vous le disiez
les jardiniers tous ceux qui s'attachent
à rendre ce golf national si beau
voulait absolument des compétitions
aussi c'est important pour les employés
du golf national
bah oui c'est important parce qu'en fait
on est on a été éduquée et dopé aux
compétitions de haut niveau c'est vrai
qu'on a eu la chance d'accueillir
beaucoup d' open de france d'accueillir
le championnat de france des jeunes des
championnats d'europe
les championnats du monde la ryder cup
en 2018 hélas d'accueillir des
événements tels que linxea pour nous c
est ça permet vraiment de redonner un
objectif et un coup de boost aux
équipements le ningxia sais c'est quoi
finalement c'est une compétition
franco-française déjà mouais exactement
c'est à dire qu'en fait ça rassemble un
champ
d'amateurs en champs de professionnels
des messieurs des dames et c'est pour ça
que c'est un événement extra fins qui
est fabuleux je trouve parce que
vraiment il ya une mixité il ya les
différents publics il ya des jeunes il
ya des très jeunes
il ya on a le numéro 2 français qui est
là on est en toile rosemère qui est qui
qui est là pour partager on va dire pour
se préparer pour partager et faire des
partages d'expériences entre berre des
amateurs de bon niveau qui se lance
et puis les joueurs professionnels qui
eux sont déjà lancées sur lesquels on
attend beaucoup justement antoine
rosaire c'est un petit peu là
on va dire était d' affiches de cet
événement numéro 2 français vous venez
le dire il a été notamment états unis il
a réussi brillante performance face à
brighton de chamboule le numéro 5
mondial
il a battu c'est important de l'avoir
aujourd'hui ça me la lumière sur cet
événement
bah oui ça m'aide à la lumière ça mais
la fierté ça donne moi je trouve ça en
tant que structure fédérale le site de
la fédération française de golf d'avoir
le numéro 2 français qui est présent sa
porte de l'intérêt et je trouve que
réellement et sam est réellement une
lumière sur l'événement et je pense que
pour toutes les personnes qui sont là
qui sont dans le champ des joueurs de
pouvoir avoir antoine rosemère à côté
d'eux c'est je pense que c'est vraiment
une plus value pour le oui alors ils les
conditions sont un petit peu compliqué
aujourd'hui est ce que vous attendez une
météo si compliqué pour les prochains
jours non non non non normalement c'est
aujourd'hui on a un temps un temps
breton ou écossais et après ça va
s'améliorer avec des conditions qui
devraient être bonnes demain avec du
beau temps demain et je crois que samedi
on doit avoir plus de 20 degrés dimanche
enfin bon des joueurs seront prêts à
dimanche mais en tout cas à dimanche il
devrait faire très très beau seul souci
sur sur cet événement c'est forcément
l'absence du public
on a tous dû faire des tests pcr pour
venir ici on est journaliste vous êtes
organisateur mais il n'y a pas de public
ici est ce que c'est un regret ouais
c'est toujours un regret c'est vrai que
deux voilà lorsqu'on laisse qu'on met
beaucoup d'énergie
à préparer des événements lorsqu'on met
beaucoup d'énergie à préparer les
terrains on mais on a envie de partager
c'est vrai que là on partage pas m'aimer
mais il n'empêche que il n'empêche que
le principal c'est de pouvoir donner la
possibilité à des joueurs professionnels
et de joueurs amateurs de pouvoir jouer
c'est la priorité
est ce que vous êtes plutôt optimiste
quand même sur le retour du public ici
au golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
ben disons que là jusqu'à présent on en
a on a dû passage on a beaucoup de
passagers je remercie l'ensemble des
personnes qui voilà qui viennent jouer
chez nous on a nos parcours qui les
parcours de l'albatros et les parcours
de l'aigle on a vraiment beaucoup de
fréquentation et ça jusqu'à présent très
honnêtement voilà on peut pas se
plaindre parce que on a eu des
conditions météo qui était
extraordinaire des parcours qui sont
dans des conditions aussi exceptionnel
l'albatros donc comme jouer y compris
par depuis longtemps pour l'open de
france est donc là qui est prêt pour le
linxea et le parcours de l'aigle sur
lequel on met beaucoup d'attention le
linxea ça sera une seule édition ici au
golf national où ça pouvait s'inscrire
ici au golf national dans l'est dans les
prochaines années là dessus je ne sais
pas mais je pense que après derrière
c'est format de tournoi je trouve que
des tournois qui à la fois rassemble les
meilleurs joueurs amateurs français
qui se destinent à une belle carrière
amateur une très belle carrière
professionnelle et les meilleurs
professionnels français
je pense que c'est une belle chose est
tout à fait et donc si on peut inscrire
sa au calendrier pourquoi pas dans la
question qu'est ce qu'on peut souhaiter
à cet événement ce week-end à bannir
météo est ce qu'on peut souhaiter s'il
meilleure météo non mais la météo sera
bien il sera bien meilleure ce qu'on
peut souhaiter céder des joueurs qui
prennent beaucoup de plaisir à jouer sur
sur le parcours de l'albatros des
amateurs qui prennent beaucoup
d'expérience des joueurs professionnels
b qui vont prendre des gains grâce grâce
aux sponsors et comme le disait antoine
j'ai eu la chance de parler avec lui
hier il me disait que c'était un
excellent en test antoine rené un
excellent test c'est une bonne
préparation pour le spd est donc si ça
lui permet de bien se préparer pour
perfé à l'usb jim ça serait une belle
semaine qui vous remerciera peut-être à
la fin du tournoi ouais nan mais je
pense qu'il faut qu'il se remercier à
lui a brûlé tout à fait merci beaucoup à
tout
et puis un nouveau véhicule utilitaire
pour les salariés du centre hydrolyse de
suez à saint-cyr-l'ecole il a été
présenté ce mercredi lors d'une
conférence de presse ce véhicule 100%
électrique va permettre aux employés de
se déplacer plus facilement sur le site
de traitement des eaux usées
le reportage de célia gars de 100 go et
de bérangère bourgoin maya me carbo
c'est le nom du véhicule utilitaire
commandé par sue est la citroën pour son
site de saint cyr l'école où les eaux
usées de la plaine de versailles sont
traités le véhicule ici en démonstration
s'inscrit dans l'objectif de suez de
réduire ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de 45% d'ici 2030 sur véhicules
livrés servira à pouvoir aider nos
agents va pouvoir faire des rondes de
surveillance de process sur un site
comme carré de réunion on est sur un
site relativement grand donc on a des
agents qui surveille que le process
fonctionne correctement le process de
de traitement des eaux ça permettra
effectivement de augmenter sa
performance parce que ça va lui
permettre de dédier du temps à faire
aussi autre chose que finalement de se
déplacer de point en point à travers ce
site accessible et utilisable sans
permis maya mi cargo est homologué
quadricycles légers au prix de 7000
euros il a une capacité d'autonomie de
75 km c'est un objet de mobilité
innovants destinés aux professionnels
ils innovent parce que il est d'abord
dans un gabarit inhabituel extrêmement
compact agile de m 41 delon simplement
il est 100% électrique dans les les
enjeux importants pour nos clients il ya
le fait que l'on cherche à proposer une
solution de mobilité pour tous qui
permet d'aller partout et aujourd'hui on
voit bien que de plus en plus de villes
impose des restrictions dans certains
quartiers pour les véhicules qui ne sont
pas électrifiés citroën a enregistré
plus de 4000 commandes et suez envisage
un déploiement rapide du quadricycle sur
ces sites dès la livraison
les huits ça fait partie de paris
métropole donc ça ça sera des foyers
dans cette région là le premier véhicule
utilitaire maya mi cargo devrait arriver
sur le site de saint cyr l'école dans
les prochaines semaines voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]